the denver nuggets if you've just joined  us shooting at a  67 clip  and right now have opened up an 18-point  lead lillard  has something to say about it and see  lillard hill that sidestep  in rhythm  can lillard get them back there he is  again  deep triple from dame the offensive side  that's  what gives that group confidence and now  let's see if  denver can answer lillard again  and he is starting to cook in that first  game which was really impressive to go  along with the points  already four here tonight so getting  great balance between the play making  and the dagger taking as we come up on  the final two minutes  denver has led by as many as 18. lillard  hits again you know what he just told